the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones video today I want to discuss
one character in particular which is
Benjen stark but I do also want to talk
about brain stark and Jon Snow because
their scenes together could reveal just
how much information Benjen Stark knew
about the bigger picture I decided to
make this video because someone recently
asked me this question on Twitter after
thinking about it I came to the
conclusion that I'm about to present to
you today since my last video was
centered around the books I want to keep
this one centered around everything we
have seen in the show I will only
reference one quote from the books just
to add a little more context but that's
it the main thing I want to talk about
is whether or not Benjen Stark knew the
truth about Jon Snow this is something
fans like to discuss but there is
something else I want to talk about
because I think there is evidence they
may suggest benjin knew a hell of a lot
more than just this so let's get into it
I think it's safe to say Uncle Benjen is
a beloved character but we don't know
that much about him we do meet him in
the very first episode and we come to
find out he is a man of the Nights Watch
who is also brothers with a Ned Stark
benjin arrives at Winterfell
during the feast which is held for King
Robert Baratheon
when benjin does arrive the first person
to greet him is his nephew Jon Snow
although we don't know much about either
one of these characters at first it does
seem very clear that they have a good
relationship with one another after they
give each other a hug John tells benjin
he was not allowed to attend the feast
because Catelyn thought it would be
insulting to have a bastard sitting
around the royal family this is when
benjin tells Jon you are more than
welcome to join the Nights Watch no
bastard was ever turned away from
providing service at the wall wall isn't
going anywhere I'm ready to sway you
you don't understand what you'd be
giving up we have no families none of us
will ever father so they don't care
about that
right you know what you meant
depending on who you ask this
conversation between John and benjin is
the basis for one very popular theory
that I want to talk about today as I'm
sure all of you know the truth about Jon
Snow's parents was one of the best-kept
secrets in Westeros but some people
believe there was one other person who
knew about this secret and that was
Benjen stark at the beginning of the
show we are led to believe Jon Snow is
Ned Stark's bastard son but we later
come to find out Ned lied about this in
order to keep Jones safe jon is actually
the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
Stark at the time of John's birth all
the Targaryen 's were getting killed in
leon and knew if Robert Baratheon ever
found out John Maz Rhaegar son he would
have him killed as well so Liana made
Ned promise to keep it a secret
it was Liana's dying wish and as far as
we know Ned took that secret to his
grave
Ned obviously never told any of his kids
or even his wife Catelyn hated John
because every time she looked at him he
was a constant reminder that the
Honorable Lord Eddard Stark [ __ ]
another woman Ned went to great lengths
to keep this a secret but could he have
told his brother Benjen Stark this is
something most of us have wondered and
would like to know unfortunately there
is only one problem as far as we know
Ned and benjin are both dead so we may
never actually find out what he knew the
only way we could probably ever find out
is if benjin had a secret diary at
Castle black or if bran had a vision of
Ned and benjin talking about this in
private
so the first thing you have to ask
yourself is why would Ned tell the
secret to benjin why would Benjy need to
know this information well depending on
how you want to look at it
I think benjin did deserve to know the
truth Liana wasn't just Ned's sister she
was benjin sister as well benjin and
Liana were also very close they actually
spent a lot of time together and later
in the books when brain is looking
through the eyes of the weirwood tree he
can see Liana and benjin playing
together in the godswood I actually read
this entire chapter in my video about
bloodraven escape at first brain thinks
it could be him and Arya playing with
wooden
but after watching them for a few
seconds he realizes it's not it's benjin
and Liana this is when I start to think
why would the author of the story decide
to show us this could there be a few
different reasons why out of all the
things bran could see in the where
wouldn't it
we are shown benjin and Liana playing
together as kids well one reason could
be to show the similarities between Aria
and Liana but another reason could be to
show just how close benjin and Liana
were this is something that Stark would
have obviously known because they all
grew up at Winterfell together even if
they all did eventually part ways once
they got a little bit older so even
though Ned made two promise to Leona I
don't think she would mind if benjin
knew when you consider the fact that
Liana benjin and Ned were all brothers
and sisters don't you think Ned would
have wanted to tell benjin what actually
happened to their sister I mean what do
you think was going through benjin's
head when all these rumors started to
circulate about the sister he loved all
throughout Westeros people were saying
Leona was kidnapped and raped by Rhaegar
which was apparently so violent and led
to her death
why would Ned allow benjin to have to
think about that for the rest of his
life what do you really want his own
brother to continue thinking his sister
was raped and killed hell no
he would probably want to give his
brother peace of mind he would want to
let him know all those crazy rumors
aren't exactly true but you have to keep
this a secret because now we have a
child's life at stake since jon is
family benjin will not have to even be
told how important it is to keep this
quiet
Ned could trust that benjin would keep
his mouth shut about this because he has
just as much love for Liana and John as
he does even though John is only a half
stark they still share some of the same
blood and we all know blood is thicker
than water
benjin is even watching over him as Ned
says the exact same thing to Jon in my
opinion there is a very good chance Ned
told benjin what happened to their
sister think about it like this after
the Mad King killed their father and
brother Ned and benjin were the only two
left from their generation their mother
was gone
their father was gone their brother was
gone and now even their baby sister was
gone
don't you think Ned and benjin would
have became even closer after something
like that besides the statues down in
the crypts of Winterfell the one thing
they had left to remember their sister
by was Jo
maybe this is another reason why benjin
was always so happy to see John not just
because he was family
but because every time he looks at John
he sees a little bit of his sister and
it reminds him of all the great times
they had together as kids when they
would chase each other around in the
godswood all right now I want to move on
to the second part of the discussion
because I believe there is some evidence
later in the show that does suggest
benjin knew more than just that by the
end of season six benjin start might
have had the answer to just about
anything and I'll show you why
after benjin disappears in the first
season we don't see him again until
season six when he rescues Brian and
Meera Reed when they escaped from the
three-eyed Ravens cave benjin saves them
before they get surrounded and over and
by more whites then he takes them
somewhere that is relatively safe at
that time then we find out some more
information about benjin and this is
what he says stab me in the gut the
sword of ice
they'll be there today to turn his
children film stop the walkers magic
from taking hold how the same way they
made the workers in the first place you
saw it yourself
dragonglass benjin said that when he led
the ranging party they went looking for
white walkers but the white walkers
ended up finding them instead one of the
white walkers stabbed the Benjen right
in the gut with his ice sword then he
left benjin there to die and hopefully
turn into a white thankfully the
children of the forest showed up and
saved his life they were able to stop
the night Kings magic from taking
control of benjin but they had to shove
dragon glass into his chest to do this
now what happens after all this is still
a bit of a mystery because benjin never
says what he has been doing the whole
time this had to have taken place in the
first season because that's when
benjin's other brothers were found by
ghost ghosts who you see be good
it's also without a doubt the other ones
jafer flowers my lord less the hand the
wolf tore off any sign of Benjen the
rest of his party it's these two my lord
the only reason why benjin's body was a
laying next to theirs was because the
children came along and saved him but
where the hell did he go did he stay out
there all by himself
trying to find more White Walkers for
over five seasons or did something else
happen in the meantime well let's think
about what benjin actually said to Bryan
when benjin said the children saved him
brain wanted to know how that happened
and that's when benjin said they were
able to save him the same way they
created the White Walkers in the first
place you saw it for yourself now this
is where it gets kind of interesting
because how the hell could benjin have
known what brain saw inside of the
weirwood net benjin wasn't inside the
cave what then when brain came out of
that vision so how did he know what
Bryan saw well I think there is really
only two logical ways to explain this
either the three-eyed raven of the
children of the forest or send and
benjin all this information through
visions or benjin is able to go inside
the weirwood net by himself now I know
we've never seen benjin do anything like
this before but you also have to
remember two very important things
not only does benjin have stark blood
the blood of the first men but he also
has that dragon glass in his chest as
far as we know there is only one other
character that has dragon glass in his
chest and that's the night king we all
know the kind of things the night king
is capable of we have seen the night
king go inside of the weirwood net with
Bryan Stark not only was he there but he
was able to manipulate that vision which
allowed him to reach out and grab bran
by the arm we know that I King got all
his powers from the children of the
forest after they inserted two
dragonglass into his chest so I think
since the children did the same thing to
benjin he may be able to do some of the
same type of things we know the children
the forests have full access to the
weirwood net and it seems like whenever
they shove dragon glass in someone it
gives them very similar abilities this
could be how benjin knew what bran had
just seen inside of the weirwood net now
let's take a look at another scene
because benjin says something else then
me think he knows things about the past
present and future
it was good to control for the night
king comes
drink
one way another it will find his way to
the world of men when he does you will
be there waiting for him and he will be
ready benjin says you must learn how to
control your visions before the night
King comes you see brain is still seeing
everything in fragments but once he's
able to piece everything together he
should be able to find all the answers
that he's looking for benjin tells him
one way or another the night King will
make his way past the wall and when he
does brain will be there waiting for him
and he will be ready benjin is basically
telling us exactly what's gonna happen
one way or another the night king will
make his way south but by the time he
reaches Bryan he will be ready after
benjin had the dragonglass put into his
chest he might have learned everything
including how it all ends now let's tie
this back into the beginning of the
video as I said before there is a very
good chance that Ned told benjin the
truth about Leona and ultimately her son
John benjin might have known this the
entire time but for some reason he did
not know the truth about John at the
beginning he definitely found out by the
end if benjin had access to the weirwood
net just like the children of the forest
and Bryan and the knight king then he
could have gotten the answers to just
about anything he wanted that's more
than likely how benjin knew brain had
seen the night Kings creation and that's
more than likely how he knew Bryan would
be ready when the night king arrives
therefore he would have seen everything
happened to do at the endgame
which means he would also have known
exactly how important Jon Snow is he may
have been watching everything the entire
time since he went missing which would
also explain how benjin showed up just
in time to save John's life if he knows
how everything will play out then he
would have known that he needed to be in
position to save John's life that way
John can go on and help bran defeat the
night king what do you think about
Benjen Stark do you believe he knew the
truth about John all the way back in the
first season also let me know if you
think benjin was in constant contact
with the children of the forest or did
he have his own access to the weirwood
net after he had the dragonglass put
into his chest leave some of your
thoughts opinions or questions down
below I would like to hear what you have
to say I want to thank everyone for
watching
video I really appreciate that and also
want to thank all of my supporters on
patreon I hope everyone has a great day
I will see you all very soon
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]